[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] me
sorry i want to muppet [ __ ] you now
hello gentlemen hello mate how are you
not bad gordon
james good to see you and you're mike
and this is steven steve thanks for
showing
richard richard how are you welcome the
most important thing about the food
tonight is straightforward and easy
but the real key is cooking for 50
diners right yes if they're not happy
with the food they've got the right not
to pay for it
that makes you look stupid that's my
reputation going down the [ __ ] pan
that's not gonna happen you know i don't
care quite frankly whether you hate my
guts but between now and 11 o'clock
i just want it right nothing more than
that yeah let's go
the starter tonight right it's a very
simple seared
crusted tuna with a watercress salad
okay guys here we go richard james and
steve now
you're working the city yes yeah you'll
handle pressure
yeah yeah now it's time to [ __ ] prove
it yes first order
four covers away table four four seeded
tuna four sea bass
four apple donuts yes chef thank you
the brigade have been shown how to make
the starter but to ensure they know what
they're doing
i'm going to run through it one more
time yeah it goes in the soy sauce first
yeah that starts to season it yes
then from there we get our wasabi we
brush it on all over
then get your seeds and sprinkle your
seeds over there we've got a sesame seed
crusted line of tuna pans really nice so
it'll sear it
and not boil it okay you focus on the
tuna yeah nothing more
turn that round see the color of the
seeds oh you're nice toasted color
so watch not too thin my slice is down
look at that if all that tuna goes out
like that yeah i can guarantee we'll
have 50 customers
i'll be paying for that now let me ask
you a question all of you
yeah now you may be from essex and
[ __ ] tight and too interested in
[ __ ] drinking
however would you pay for that yes yes
yeah i would
[Music]
listen to it that's searing the tuna in
yes
what's the matter the olive oil bottle
is lifted off melted
oh [ __ ] hell um
everywhere on that stove is [ __ ]
piping hot yeah if we do it again the
whole [ __ ] place is gonna go up in
fire okay
you guys work under pressure each and
every day get organized yes
golden ripping it's [ __ ]
it's because it's cooked to [ __ ] that's
why in the bin
i need two seconds two seconds what do
you need more olive oil
more olive oil come on
stop stop stop it's burnt my man if you
just follow me
yeah and you ask me questions i'm there
with every step of the way that you're
going through
okay but you know quite frankly that's
nearly 20 quid worth of tuna in the
[ __ ] bin yes
so start again sell it away please yes
because that's gonna be like a [ __ ]
limp dick
let's clear down we'll do the whole
[ __ ] thing again yes
[Music]
my name's richard and i'm a greedy
bastard therefore i love the cook
i'm half italian so i tend to cook a lot
of italian food
my name's steven i enjoy cooking thai
japanese
classic english dishes with like a
little twist you know maybe a bit of
horseradish in the match just to
flare up a bit you know my name's james
i can't see the stress of the kitchen
being any worse than what we're already
used to
i get called a prick all day long so
golden ramsay called me a freak i really
kind of affect me
in a pressurized environment isn't
anything new to any one of us it's got
to be done it's got to be done there and
then
and if you make a [ __ ] up it can be
costly as long as government sermon says
you boys have done a good job i'm proud
of you that's going to make me happy
i think we pull it off we're fematic so
clearly we're better than everyone else
so um yeah it won't be a problem
all we've got now is four portions each
to do that's all
watercress leaves bean shoots in there
yeah some coriander
yeah spring onions in there yeah a
little bit of dressing yes
add a touch of ginger honey and sesame
oil dressing and place it on a bit of
thinly sliced radish
because it's so thick yeah what we'll do
is put two nice slices on there
now are you happy with those yes yeah
because i am they look fantastic
table four go please yes clear down and
start again yes
we've seen that table come out a long
time ago and
nobody else another tape has just come
out now but that's been over 25 minutes
come on yes this is stunning [ __ ]
beautifully cooked tuna
that has to be served properly yeah come
on let's go
clean your [ __ ] down hello hey big boy
yeah cutters that's it away from the hot
plate
we may be slow but at least the food's
going out looking [ __ ] fantastic yes
yeah [ __ ] come on
place up forget the mate guys gordon yes
[ __ ] hell guys
we're not down the [ __ ] boozer now
let's go service please wait what's your
table yes
thank you uh both hog yeah
i don't like fish but this was
pleasantly surprising
i loved it i loved the sesame seeds and
on the bed of mooli it gave me a nice
crispness so
i'm very impressed okay good here guys
here comes jb with the results
obviously slow how many customers are
going to pay for their staff
very good news everyone everyone
everyone is picking yeah
that's [ __ ] good news yeah what's not
good news for me on a personal front
without the customers known
is what went in the bin that's nothing
to be proud of
however well done now that doesn't mean
to say we've got to start pissing our
pants and [ __ ] up the sea bass
because 50 customers can refuse to pay
for the pass yeah
it's a good start but do we get [ __ ]
harder let's go
next on the menu a delicious sea bass
with soy sauce it's easy to cook
but will it be too much for the brigade
jax at least come back and send the
[ __ ] thing
yeah because right now this whole
[ __ ] thing's on my shoulders
it's time to get to grips with my pigs
and i'll get some expert help to judge
slepty chef's recipes
right ainsley get your big [ __ ] chops
in there
welcome back to the f word tonight the
brigade are getting a taste of what it's
like to be a real chef
and believe me it's not about pouncing
around launching [ __ ] cat food or
washing up liquid
marco pierre white my ex-mentor is
actually judging the daily mail dog food
competition
how [ __ ] sad is that they're asking
readers to send in their favorite
recipes for homemade dog food
it's official celebrity chefs have
clearly gone to the [ __ ] dogs
pathetic
so i'm looking for dogs ranging from
short fat dumpy little sort of grunters
i can't resist
i'm entering a recipe into the daily
mail competition i just can't decide
whether it should be one of gary's
ainslie's anthony's or marcos so i'm
going to get the four dogs to make the
decision for me
and i want the dogs to look like the
chefs just looking at his eyes that is
definitely ainsley hey
well he's definitely docile is he stupid
i said hit rock bottom mike's mentor guy
called marco poy is now sort of a
chairman of
sort of
what about anthony well he's certainly
[ __ ] ugly
at
enough
foreign
spiky hair slightly grey bit of a
six-pack going on
that's definitely gary thank you now
where's the kitchen
this way downstairs each dog is going to
dine on one dish taken from their
celebrity chef's cookbook
and i've wrote in some of the staff from
bassy dog's home to do the cooking
[Music]
pork chops with apple tart topping i'm
not too sure the dog's gonna make that
one you know
what is that in there cheesy chicken
breast well it looks like
vomit we are in a dog's home
[Music]
the first time i've actually seen one of
uh wazza's recipes actually put together
let's hope the [ __ ] book didn't sell
that well
so uh pork chop chester chow mein tuna
with bath with vinegar
the [ __ ] what is that boat thing
cheesy chicken greta and crunch crunch
yes judgment time which chess recipe
will i enter into the daily mail pet
food competition
the winner will be the meal wolf down in
the fastest time
now gentlemen please enjoy your dog's
dinner yes be careful when you eat it
don't slobber yes anthony apart from
being the [ __ ] ugliest
try somehow to keep the food
on the plate okay let's cut all that
[ __ ]
french crap out marco pierre white mark
peter white from now on we're in south
[ __ ] london so we keep it real
this is the comfy of tuna with a
pepperoni and a balsamic vinegar
dressing
happy with the croissant nice and pink
right ainsley off we go
[Music]
come on get your big [ __ ] chops in
there right gaza let's go
free pork chop with the apple pie
topping and off we go
excuse me hello hey
hey anthony sit nice please and just try
to look happy for once
cheesy chicken gratin crunch what the
[ __ ] are you thinking about when you
came with that idea
as time ticks by all the dogs are
tucking into their grub well
all except one who's turning his nose up
at the posh nosh
please eat some salad or something
anthony come on i'll leave you in peace
eat your dinner anthony
pork chop isn't exactly been wolfed down
marco can't keep his food on his plate
but ainsley's chow mein on the other
hand is going down a storm
and it's hard to believe but waz's
chicken brick has been rejected outright
ready steady munch eat
ainsley you have the best and the
fastest dog's dinner in town at one
minute 35 and
well anthony i always knew it not even a
[ __ ] dog would eat your food
cooked chicken shredded 175 grams egg
noodles 100 grams of bean sprouts
yes amazing it's official the dogs gave
your recipe the pours up so i'm sending
it to the daily mail dog food
competition
let's see what marble white thinks about
it [ __ ] good luck
i think it's time to do something to
show these celebrity chefs enough is
enough
so i've decided to set up a celebrity
cookbook amnesty
send me all the celebrity cookbooks that
you think are crap
and i'll dispose of them next
of course i want faster yes and better
imagine 50 customers paying for the
[ __ ] sea bass as well as 50 customers
paying for the starter
with two thirds of the way there if that
happens right
big
watch me you've really got to watch me
now yeah
[Music]
center of the plate again stay nice and
tidy yes so easy
time for the main course a delicious sea
bass in sorrel sauce
[Music]
sea vess for me absolute delicacy the
flavor
not just of the flesh but the skin is
extraordinary
fill it come down the backbone nice long
strokes
every time i fill it a sea bass it's a
certified pleasure because they're
extraordinary fish
look at it absolutely beautiful
three nice portions score and skin
and the beauty of this fish is that it's
so robust but so delicate
in flavor sauce lava butter
shallots salt
pepper spread down the shallots with no
colour that's absolutely crucial
verma sea bass is very sweet and rich so
therefore we need a really nice dry
white wine to find that balance
reduce fish stock in
reduce cream in bring it back up to a
boil
sieve sorrel
the flavor it gives to the fish sauce is
extraordinary it's
peppery a little bit like rocket it also
has this really nice acidic
tanginess to it into the cream just to
infuse
lovely hot pan olive oil season the bass
salt pepper just before the olive oil
starts to smoke
sea bass in skin side down
[Applause]
turn it over i just faced over the bass
keeps our skin
really nice and crispy broccoli
cooking for about two and a half minutes
maximum drain
still got a really nice dark green color
see that's out they can hear that
skin cracking away the song
has done this magic the crispy skin the
sea bass
the real earthy flavor of the broccoli
and then this wonderful peppery vinegary
sauce the perfect way starting summer
delicious sea bass with sorrel sauce
done don't burn the [ __ ] bats okay
nice two minutes till it starts to brown
yeah nicely colored yeah
just touch your seat back on there for
me yeah it's two cooks
yeah don't laugh at me i'm not laughing
now no no no no no
the bass is way overcooked it's going to
take three and a half four minutes to
cook maximum yeah
yeah start again yes yeah don't flip
that fish until there's a really nice
golden brown
bin service please back in your pocket
[ __ ] it out what's going on guys [ __ ]
you now are you not here just to
spectate and [ __ ] go back and tell
your mates what a hard one you had let's
go
yeah you got to get in there you know
that nothing [ __ ] difficult
let's go i cannot burp my hands of [ __ ]
right steve
just for your info it's the third time
this table it's your first table
right we've only sent two tables both
your sea basses have been cooked to [ __ ]
he's looking all right yeah you stopped
calling me [ __ ] mate yeah
yeah gordon's fine yeah thank you james
yeah and if i give you respect call you
by [ __ ] james at least call me
[ __ ] gordon yes
i don't mind but [ __ ] mate forget
about it yeah
james yes at least come back and sing
the [ __ ] thing
yeah sure because right now this whole
[ __ ] thing's on my shoulders
sorry [ __ ] and if you're standing next
to me with me it makes me feel that you
care about it
yeah yeah do you care i don't care well
[ __ ] you show me something then yes
thank you chef thank you chef mate was
my first time ever having sea bass
so i was impressed i liked it i'm really
not a fish eater so for me to say that
it's really you know it was tender it
was moist
it also been cooked slowly for the flesh
but the skin had been panning
quite quickly
[Music]
they're all [ __ ] turned have we got
any sea bass left because iron man
right come around here yeah
he's burnt three pants full now you've
burnt it
we started with 75 portions of bass
we've got half the dining room not
served yet
we [ __ ] so many baths so early we've
run out
i'm going to it some more baths but when
i fill up these bags when we get them
can we [ __ ] cook them properly
richard yeah chef yes
hello quintus here listen to me
on top of 75 just under 100 portions
of bass hello don't [ __ ] it
i know you're not a professional chef
you know that but you are a [ __ ]
bright spark
and all i beg for for one hour is just a
little bit of [ __ ] intelligence i'm
sorry
sorry chef
did you enjoy your minecraft makos was
good
yes you sound french yeah i'm french
it's not like raymond blanc banging on
about how [ __ ] our british food is again
did you enjoy your bath i enjoyed my bus
but yeah where the sea bus was probably
cool sorry i'm just nodding off two
seconds
did you enjoy your bath not as much as
the sausage
could you put your tongue out for me
please got a [ __ ] ball bearing on the
end of it
would you expect me to take your pilot
seriously when you've got all that
shrapnel in there
jump right twist please wait chef what
do they say jb
yeah far too long far too long that's
the main campaign
big big problem on this one steve that
first table you cooked four times
yeah what were the results how many
customers out of 50 want to pay for
their dinner
uh 21 unknown thing 21 yeah
why far too long to receive the main
course and as well some of them find it
exactly bland
it's a line caught sea bass yeah roasted
in olive oil
it's the best quality [ __ ] sea bass
21
customers refusing to pay for the main
course i don't know why you keep on
laughing i think you find it a joke
don't you let's get our priorities right
yeah
yeah [ __ ] the stupid [ __ ] laughing
snickering hey because it's not you
looking good right now
yeah i'm good if you give me those vibes
i'm gonna tell you
you got those vibes whether you don't
mean it inside i just wanted to come
back
this is important for me as it is for
you yeah so when you're finishing on a
high
yeah okay are you ready yeah let's see
clear down let's get ready for dessert
yes
next on the menu foodie gobshite janet
street porter is back in my kitchen this
is fish stew fish stew
well whatever you [ __ ] want to call
it golden and i'll find out what taxi
drivers
really think of me you want his cab [ __ ]
off
welcome back to the f word now genesee
porter last year beat me in a challenge
only because we had a [ __ ] panel of
blind tasters that were
so crap taste and distinction
obsessed with low-fat food so i lost the
challenge she's back for more and
this time she's got [ __ ] no chance
right the rules are simple the
challenger picks their best dish and i
have to try and beat that with my
version
the winner is the nets
oh no sarah the winner for today is yes
this time i'm determined to win um so
don't tell me a low-fat soup this
is fish stew
well whatever you [ __ ] want to call
it golden right the thing about making
this
yes is that you make the fish stock uh
the day before which you get the fish
manga
to cut the fish into phillips and remove
all the bones so you just got to get a
carrier bag
full of bones right it sounds a bit
cheffy though you know that
golden it's practical so you make the
fish stop the day before
by using uh onions you sweat onions
celery maybe a bit of carrot lots of
herbs thyme and so on
in a massive pan the biggest pan you
possibly can right
and some white wine are you agreeing
with this sauce
in the background i'm listening but not
getting very excited
janet's making a fish too and i'm doing
something sort of almost like a little
classic bully base but a very quick
bullier base
because we haven't got time to do a
long-winded three and a half four hour
classic french bully bay so
it's a very simple fish stew but then
with red mullet fennel carrots shallots
a touch of white wine
but the secret ingredient today of
course is the perno
and that goes brilliantly with a fish
just like the good old days we used to
have the burner on black you got no idea
the hard time i got after losing against
the challenge you last time you know
that what happened did you get your leg
pulled down apart
i mean no just in the kitchen they're
saying [ __ ] you now chef you lost to
janet street porter you're beaten by a
woman
who will not put up with fancy food
things in piles unnecessary sauces
do you know on the last challenge i
actually let you win you know that
gordon
bollocks you tried your hardest oh my
stop
falling over janet you're right my dolly
yeah i just had a slight disaster
it's all right okay fish straight in
and i mean really straight in guts have
been taken out
and straight in look at that then with
the pans
i'm gonna do now is just glaze the pan
with a touch
of purno and white wine
what i'm gonna do so get all that flavor
from the bottom of the pan
is look
wash out the pan in she goes
and then in there again
nice
[Music]
i don't know if you've got fish heads
there or prawn heads can i have them i'm
going to put them in my soup
no i'm not giving them to you no
you shellfish [ __ ]
right that's [ __ ] out of order i'm
sorry because you asked me for my head
and i
have not shot these vegetables as fine
as i would have done because if i wasn't
being finished
filmed on [ __ ] national television i
would have whacked them all in the
blender
and that's a bit of a top tip for all
the [ __ ] at home yes
we can't chop as small as you know
supersonic golden i'm now putting my
fish in
okay good how do fish take the cook well
i'm going to put in first the scallops
because they're the thickest
i unlike these recipes you know that
this is such a simple recipe
i think putting the saffron in is key
because the saffron colors the potatoes
they look fantastic yeah
so i'm going to put my little bits of
fish in a pan and unlike janet
i'm gonna cook them separately okay
because they cook very very quickly
because they're small little bits of
fish
are you in favor of my cookbook msc what
to make people send in useless cookbooks
yeah
unwanted cookbooks the sad thing is and
you
you've said a lot about this that people
in britain
buy cookery books but don't cook
it's like porn they just go to bed every
night instead of having a shag
they read a cookery book they cook
it i call it cookery pool they cook they
cook they cook for my chocolate i hope
it doesn't go on in your household
so what do you have sex or do you read
cookery books i would do both
treat it like a dinner in between
courses read
right janet yes darling this is looking
fantastic
yeah start getting nervous please yes
how are you doing i'm doing fine i can't
i'm just doing a bit of sieving
do you panic when things go pear-shaped
at dinner parties in terms of when
you're in
dinner parties i worked too hard do you
give dinner parties
do i [ __ ] you can't charge them they
come home can you i don't give them
parties
i call on a sparrow moment and say i'm
cooking chicken pie want to come round
i'm cooking fish jar week on saturday
hold on not chicken pie with pastry
janet surely
well people the gays and calorie
watchers
don't eat the pastry gays don't eat
pastry you're having a laugh aren't you
i've got lots of friends that are going
they love pastry
why they're fat guys
janet
looks a nice color it tastes great
does it be scared be scared be very
scared
you think i'm gonna lose yeah two
challenges on the track you got another
thing coming
right six is almost ready gonna leave
them both to simmer now between eight
and ten minutes and then
later on janet loses
[Music]
crispy doughnuts yeah so it's a nice
yeast batter
yeah now the most important thing with
these yeah is just keep them submerged
under the oil
yeah out into the sugar so
with a donut we're gonna serve a really
nice slice of apple fritter yes yeah
okay yeah in there like that off
and in yeah okay
right watch fresh yogurt yeah
maple syrup and that's a really nice
fine apple puree in there yeah
look out with your fritter
again out get it dry
yeah and look i slice
bingo finished yeah okay a word of
warning
these are deep fat fryers be [ __ ]
careful be careful under no
circumstances
do we get this and start running around
the [ __ ] kitchen
with that stevie i'm [ __ ] serious
don't laugh
just for five minutes don't laugh yeah
yeah let's go guys
move up let's get desserts out here and
let's get 50 [ __ ] desserts paid for
i'm so determined to get everyone
cooking sunday lunch even if that means
taking on some of my least favorite
people
taxi come on you miserable [ __ ] oh come
on
taxi come on how are you can't get a cab
i wonder why the london cab driver what
was he done to upset you
um i think they are perhaps now the most
frustrating
drivers on the planet they give you the
the
big one and the little one golden
on your bike son no way mate
golden you want this ken [ __ ] off
a couple of years ago i upset these guys
on telly and ever since that night they
refused to pick me up so i'm here to
make amends
one's in trouble he can't cook to save
his life i just hope he's in a good mood
because normally they are miserable
[ __ ]
i've always relied on my wife for 10
years
so that when i get in from work on one
of them there'd be a nice dinner on the
table i've never been able to take that
in
out to cook i've always ate the dinner
i'm not worried about where it came from
or whatever
anything can cook it's a sandwich
a hot cross farm or something you can
cook like bacon and that
and sausage but not like a proper big
dinner
i split up with my wife and then uh i've
got the two kids and
i'm forever getting them takeaways
whenever i've got um
they're not eating healthy food cool
what a shit-off
how old are the kids uh alfie's nine
olivia is nearly seven
uh-huh so born a girl yep and you've
never cooked for them
never you can't even do beans on toast
well no
i can do beans on toast i'm on about a
nice lunch for them or something like
that because whatever you do to those
kids now it's a reflection of you isn't
it exactly courses
we've got hard work here ahead of us
yeah yeah
[Music]
fascinating every time you get into a
cab the meat is always off yes
ah no wonder you guys are so rich you've
got around a few quick summer
it's gonna take a lot to get this
lightly laid out the dark ages and
comfortable in the kitchen
looking for the dish that's got nine or
ten uses start off with a
shepherd's pie lovely but the most
important thing about that is the mints
are making a really nice savory mince
lovely because on the back of that once
it's been used for a
shepherd's pie you can just evolve it
spaghetti
yeah then you've got um you know lasagna
curried mince with some seasoning do you
have two on the stove
um i'll do it yeah i love guy
this is what i might say exactly
johnny i am known for all of this you're
making me
you're making me nervous turn the
[ __ ] stove on
i'll peel the onions yeah you peel the
carrots
let the knife do the work look just lift
the knife up and just push the carrots
down
okay all the way through that's it nice
and slow nice and slow
oh nearly voila voila look at this
so there's only chance i'm working with
you in a restaurant
yeah so far no no
um the hot plate stands this high so we
thought straight away we've never really
seen
a little head coming with the hot plate
all right the garlic chop it nice and
fine nice slices
all in good man give it a good mix all
right man
fresh thyme take a little bit like that
yeah and just have a little bit more
try this yeah it's a herb but it's so
so nice
nice little spice to it right at the end
like an adding but it's nice and mellow
right now that's sweaty down add some
tomato puree
half a glass of red wine and lamb mints
[ __ ] without putting it on the floor
johnny now you got them on the [ __ ]
suede gucci buckles
oh [ __ ] you've got mints on your gold
bars
beef stock and worcester sauce then turn
down the heat to simmer
special time with the kids at the
weekend yeah yeah this can be frozen
and that's a way of sort of just getting
organized yep
oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] hell aren't there
new tiles you guys just put down
yeah so are they legit can we stand on
them without food do we get done for
standing on solid goods
she's making me out of right dodgy
character
i thought all cabbies are dodging back
into the pan
and back onto the stove jolly please
yeah we'll do and you know what as well
go on slowly feeling more confident
ready yeah
nice little mash thank you
into there you're almost like icing a
cake
yeah that's a nice bit of cheese on top
now pop it in there plastic
healthy olivia all right thanks man
listen to me
golden's here hi guys [ __ ] lori
jerry at the bottom yeah getting them
involved right now
they've got these memories as they go up
tell you what they are looking
absolutely fantastic
and they get to eat properly mango mango
[Music]
who needs takeaways when you got that
beautiful yeah really one crucial
question do you want dad to cook this
again
yes yeah what do you think mummy would
think
schmidt got smacked this is how
sunderland should be
well yeah but it's only you can make the
effort you're the only person that can
do this you know well they're an age
where
they're gonna remember everything thank
you very much you've done it
he's never had to cook in his life
before now he's got no choice because
he's got to look after his two kids and
you know that sunday lunch there has to
be 10
000 times better than a [ __ ] takeaway
for your kids
taxi stevie four porsche's away
coming up let's go table 12 stevie
hey brown very quickly be very careful
get your spider in there
and keep them dumped under the oil so
they cook evenly
turn this gas down find yourself
yeah they are flipping them over oh come
on i know there you go
right listen listen you stop okay get
rid of that [ __ ] burnt charcoal first
yeah you take care of the apples yeah
okay yeah what really
scares me if we're gonna giggle and
laugh and [ __ ] make this
it's too dangerous guys yeah cause i'm
gonna look a [ __ ] idiot if one of you
scolded yourself
with first-degree burns
[ __ ] sake i'm not [ __ ] running out
of
everyone out of these we're [ __ ] by the
way yeah serve two weeks from now on
okay
so if you don't run out guys yes
a gap in the middle so good
put them on there where's the sugar
please for the doughnuts take two from
here
sugar please
wash your hands put it down the shed
too hard why'd you put them on the
spider like that that's what [ __ ] them
over
oh bollocks man
no i just i need to stop everybody grab
some cold oil please
put gem on then no i don't want any
jamming [ __ ] anywhere
richard yes richard richard look at me
the reason why i'm doing this because i
can't [ __ ] trust you guys with a
panda [ __ ] hot oh we know that
seriously then when i asked you to get
serious it's just a [ __ ] bunch of
giggles
yeah and you know i know you're not
professional chefs but i just want a
little bit of [ __ ] hey
safetyness now and that's why i'm
standing here before some [ __ ] scolds
themselves
badly yeah okay finish what you're doing
oh yeah no say hey i've asked for it
about ten times yeah yeah
so i don't wanna i don't i'll cook them
you just certainly put them on the plate
i'm just letting you know
let me let me finish i'm letting you
know because you're the best one here
so hopefully those other two get the
[ __ ] message okay all right just put
them on the plate for me and send the
[ __ ] things okay
yes chefs thank you let's [ __ ]
yeah and for the last three hours you've
been calling me mate
okay okay sorry he's a parent why are
you so [ __ ] chippy
i'm not chipping right gordon golden
james i'd be greatly appreciated for the
next 20 minutes
gordon good i'm not your [ __ ] mate
next on the menu it's judgement time in
the recipe challenge you know what
honey yes no it's very close to score
three
two two and it's the end of a very
very long night i felt there's a big
[ __ ] monkey on my back this evening
because
[ __ ] me was i doing a lot
welcome back i can't wait to see janet
street paula's face when she loses this
challenge
john baptist you'll taste that
taste what a real fish soup should taste
like not your finger janet [ __ ] know
where that's been
you just put your finger in my soup
that's all right
hurry up yeah and put madame porter out
of her [ __ ] misery please yes
okay let's go yeah hello guys
how are you do you want to see
really delicate flavors it's not the
best fish
it's got a lot of chili in it i like the
spice
okay where's that lazy frog okay it
wasn't difficult
yeah what was a very classic quick pull
your bass
what are they saying no no i just said
it it's too [ __ ] hot janet it's
forgotten
i love you no yeah the preference it was
delicious it was meaty
full-bodied bit like me bit like your
[ __ ] butlers
give me kiss now get out
oh
yes
[Music]
right now time for some posh totty trini
and susanna
okay the pigs have been here a week now
they take a lot of looking after but the
kids are really rising to the challenge
our duties who's gonna clean up the poo
really
okay there you go
oh look jack come here look at his
little ear look
she's cut quite badly on the rear see
the top of the rear what they're doing
is they're catching the clip
on the fence so when she's scratching
her ears that clip
on the back of her ear is pulling so
it's bleeding kevin hi gordon
so called in christine and kevin to get
some advice the breeders who have bought
the pigs from last week
we brought you a little prezi for them
thank you what is it
it's a bit of a treat this hollow tree
stump should satisfy the pig's natural
desire
for a good old scratch
i want to talk to christian about their
ears look because see the blood where
they've been catching
if we don't clean it up it's going to
get infected so you've done a really
good job in spotting that so we just
clean it up with some cotton wool
some warm salted water which will make
them squeal but at least it will have
the
antiseptic effect and these little
piggies squealed all the way home
[Music]
it may sound harsh but it really is in
the pig's best interest
they definitely won't bite no no no no
pigs squeal i mean they squeal as if
they're being murdered
and they fight i mean they don't want to
be turned upside down on their bottom so
even though it's it's not actually that
much of a discomfort for them
uh they don't want to be there cool they
don't like there is being clean do they
i think we should give them a little
treat now with an apple or something
don't you
corn jack feed them nicely one each
the pigs certainly let you know when
they're in any discomfort so i'm going
to make sure these girls
live a life of luxury
hey ready yeah let's go guys please yes
just take them off us
richard james i should be there and you
should be here
yeah i saw the first [ __ ] pan of
donuts charcoal
yeah send the [ __ ] place yes
i'm seriously unhappy with that because
out of those 50 customers you managed to
cook for one table
but when i saw the way they were
overcooked from the beginning there's no
way on earth
you guys are ready to step up and
[ __ ] cook donuts you cook one table
out there i hope the [ __ ]
okay they're paying for them well that
was a bit of a letdown okay
yeah and thanks for calling me chef
that's all i wanted from the out
thank you very much clear down
it was crispy and sugary
and it was everything i wanted a dessert
appearance wise i wasn't that impressed
kind of looked like two brown balls just
stuck
there so i prodded it and then nice kind
of the apples kind of came
drooling out sort of thing and i thought
oh this looks interesting i love the
pudding
but i don't think it does make up for
the fact that we did wait for such a
long time for our mayo
that was a tough call okay gordon okay
feedback for the donuts please
they are quite disappointed about the
waiting time few people think that the
donut is a bit greasy
that was a donut so they're supposed to
be cooked in [ __ ] fat
how many customers are gonna pay for
their doughnuts okay we're having 12
none per year for the for the bonus
there's a fresh apple compote injected
into the donut
before they went to the table let's
start off with the starters
the seller of tuna yeah brilliant well
done all 50 customers agreed to pay
for that [ __ ] starter the negative
side we wasted a lot
yeah the positive side they all paid for
it the sea bass
21 customers refuse to pay for it a lot
of waste
a long way and there's a 12 refuse to
pay
so the total well done 117 dishes paid
for
yeah more importantly you [ __ ] hung
in there yes
the challenge was for you guys to cook
for every [ __ ] table and make sure
those customers paid
i felt there's a big [ __ ] monkey on
my back this evening because [ __ ] me was
i doing a lot i think you could see that
richard would you open your own
restaurant now yeah a piece of pizza
well done can we get a drink now can you
get a drink cool [ __ ] essex boys
yeah now [ __ ] off and get a drink i
think [ __ ] i wasn't born in essex
you